well there he is the man of the hour
corbin burns 29 in the third innings
that's right no walks 49 strikeouts
carlson's had big numbers in the first
inning
and carlson chase is 97 that dips down
and it's the first out of the day well
the streak's alive he's yet to walk a
hitter evan is on third base for nolan
arnotto
now arenado gets one pass short and
that's gonna break the ice for the
cardinals
nolan arenado makes it one nothing as
edmond scores
two hits one run now for st louis and
here comes matt carpenter
three for 11 with a couple homers in his
career against the starter for milwaukee
and that one's lifted to shallow center
kane racing in gonna be a tough play and
it drops
and arenado is going to round third here
comes the throw and it is
in time
jack flaherty for me you look look at
certain players that were affected by
the pandemic shortened season yeah it
affected jack flaherty
vogelback for the series is one for
three he has walked twice and struck out
one and two
jim reynolds the crew chief is at first
tony randazzo at second john lipka over
at third the pitch vogelback hits it
hard on the ground it's a fair ball
caught by goldschmidt moving into fowl
territory underhanding to flaherty
covering nicely done he catches
everything doesn't he does o'neill bader
and kissner coming up corbin burns ready
and here it is strike him out swinging
burns with strikeout number two in the
game and the matter is going to be
harrison bader
and he gets bader and sets a new record
52 strikeouts and no walks it's the most
case before issuing the walk
to start a season
he tops ken lee jansen's record of 51
set in 2017 and there you are he broke
your record as a starter
35
in 2013. flaherty with a homer and two
rbis going two for 12 this year
here he comes again hey struck him out
swinging
and he strikes out the side
with a base hit mixed in there
and now their hottest hitter avasale
garcia stepping up
got him garcia down on strikes first
punch out of the day for jack flaherty
arayas is the batter
popped up
arenado
finds it the flip down shades see he
still has the shades up he picks up the
ball
now watch this
old school flips down the pop-down
shades jackie bradley jr two hits in his
last 22 at bats all for seven in the
series a left-handed hitter
bradley jr to center
vader glides over
tommy edmond to lead off the third
inning the ball and two strikes to
edmond that's nasty dylan carlson's
coming up
and
that's daniel vogelbach fair ball on
there
dylan carlson said it hit his foot
[Music]
he's going to hang around and see if
that can you review that
you don't you don't stand in the box if
it doesn't hit you yeah there's no
question that was right off there goes
craig council
still getting another word here in
well we reviewed it matt
and it looks like yes we did that we got
it right
yeah
we got it right
like i said hitters are not very good
actors you can very much tell what
happened by the reaction of the hitter
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
at-bat continues after the foul ball
this place might go nuts if the walk
record gets broke right here and no more
craig counsel for the rest of the game
as you saw him head to the tunnel
ejected from the contest here in the
third carlson sends one to left bradley
jr racing over to the line adjusts
on the move and makes the catch
and to redirect his route to retire
carlson two away i think correct
council's gonna go for the runway and
say well you know what he was arguing
for not you could clearly see this hits
right off of the top
of the right foot of dylan carlson
pretty obvious
even daniel vogelbach kind of gave up on
the play and was like hey maybe we got a
free out here
you know it's interesting when john paul
was talking about the wind it looked
like it played uh jackie bradley pretty
much uh had a hard time with that ball
down the left field line he almost
overran it it looks like the wind is a
real factor out in the outfield
and bradley jr goal glover in center
field one year with boston
goldschmidt
takes the pitch down the pike
[Applause]
that's basically what what's made burnt
so effective we've seen that cutter
96-97
takes a little bit off that's almost a
slider at 86 miles an hour so we've seen
the cutter the slider and we've also
seen the curve ball
so he's just not a one-trick guy
goldschmidt lines that one up and sends
it to bradley junior and left
a two-out base runner for st louis so
one in scoring position with one out and
back to the top of the order in colton
wong and it is wong at the plate and the
pitch to colton is swung on and missed
chase to breaking ball good pitch by
flaherty
and it is kane at the plate
pisner sets up inside on the o2 pitch
and it's a called strike three kane
frozen on that pitch on the inner half
matt carpenter veteran
saint louis cardinal lead it off
and burns spots that one beautifully
for the strikeout his sixth of the day
so we'll start with kisner
good battle here for kisner and he loses
out on it to corbin burns strikeout
number eight of the afternoon we're only
in the fifth jack flaherty's coming up
who currently holds the record for most
strikeouts between walks but it's an
active race because garrett cole has a
number at 56 in a row he pitched
yesterday so burns passes him for now
then cole might top him later this week
and he puts away flowers here comes a
tie
tommy edmond one for two stolen base in
a run scored edmond started the first
with a single
only man to score today and he's on
board again
reaches for a second time and the streak
has come to a close
corbin burns has finally issued a free
pass for the first time this season
bag's full of cardinals for kisner bader
arnado and goldschmidt are on
and that is sent out to deep right
garcia backing to the track and he's got
it
and shaw's been their best bat in this
series he doubled his first time up
popped out
in the
fourth just looks like his concentration
has increased every time they've gotten
a runner in scoring position it just
looks like his his execution of pitches
has gotten even sharper
shaw goes fishing for out number one
vogelback hanging out at second omar
nirvaya's with two outs in the tying run
at second base cabrera warming up in the
bowl from the cardinals look potentially
jackie bradley jr on the on deck circle
that's a drive to deep center and bader
backing up he's got some room
goldschmidt a base hitting a walk today
he's also bounced to short
so he's feeling pretty confident right
here in this event he's feeling pretty
good about where he's at his sight lines
are good i think he's feeling pretty
good about his situation he sees the
ball well there's your chance here
lorenzo kane lines it up
tosses home edmond racing in and the
throw is money
they got it
here's kissner
jack flaherty some 95s and 96s and we
haven't seen anything above 88 miles an
hour yet from suitor kisner up the
middle juan tough play fades away and
he's got him
oh that's smooth
well paul goldschmidt is going to have
another opportunity to drive in a run in
a stadium that he loves to hit in
does so much damage in this ballpark in
the past there's a check to first ball
skips away
and then comes the second run for st
louis today lane thomas scores
it's two nothing
a free pass for goldschmidt matt
carpenter about to climb in
carpenter
to center
in the sunshine kane
yep he's got it tyrone taylor is coming
up
taylor swings through pitches up reyes
strikes out the side game over